Hey, look at that couple.
They are smooching!
Don't they know that people can see them?
Public display of affection bugs me, you know?
I know many women like kissing, hugging and holding hands in public,...
...and they say it's a way of expressing your love for each other,...
...but I'm afraid I disagree with it.
I mean, don't you think you should keep private matters private?
Why display it in public?
Why do you want to let everybody know that you're in love?
I guess we don't see eye to eye on that subject.
I am one of those girls who think it is such a sensitive and romantic way to express your love for your significant other.
I think people should feel free to express themselves emotionally and physically...
...without having to worry about what other people might think.